meine damen und herren heute ist ein
überaus trauriger tag für unser land
der tiefe schmerz über den gewaltsamen
tod so vieler mitbürger denen die
menschen in hanau hält empfinden den
empfinde ich und den empfinden menschen
in ganz deutschland
ich denke jetzt vor allem an die
familien und freunde der ermordeten
niemand kann von uns ermessen welches
leid der täter über sie gebracht hat
ich trauere mit ihnen und spreche ihnen
meine tiefe anteilnahme aus ich hoffe
dass die anteilnahme unzähliger menschen
in deutschland und auch darüber hinaus
in ein wenig kraft geben möge ich denke
auch an die verletzten und wünsche ihnen
dass sie nicht nur die körperlichen
folgen überwinden können sondern auch
die seelischen das schreckliche erlebnis
dass hinter ihnen liegt ich habe mich
seit dem frühen morgen über den stand
der ermittlungen in hanau unterrichten
lassen
dafür habe ich gespräche mit dem
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer mit
der bundesjustizministerin lambrecht dem
hessischen ministerpräsidenten bouffier
und hanaus oberbürgermeister kaminsky
geführt auch während des europäischen
rates in brüssel werde ich fortlaufend
über den weiteren gang der ermittlungen
und über den zustand der verletzten
informiert werden ich hatte auch die
gelegenheit mit dem herrn
bundespräsidenten über diese
entsetzliche tat zu sprechen
für eine abschließende bewertung ist es
noch zu früh
es wird alles unternommen um die
hintergründe dieser entsetzlichen morde
bis ins letzte aufzuklären
doch weiß derzeit vieles darauf hin dass
der täter aus rechtsextremistischen
rassistischen motiven gehandelt hat aus
hass gegen menschen mit anderer herkunft
anderen glauben oder anderem aussehen
rassismus ist ein gift der hass ist ein
gift und dieses gift
ist irrt in unserer gesellschaft und es
ist schuld an schon viel zu vielen
verbrechen von den untaten des nsu über
den mord an walter lübke bis zu den
morgen von halle
die bundesregierung und alle staatlichen
institutionen stehen für die rechte und
würde eines jeden menschen in unserem
land wir unterscheiden bürger nicht nach
herkunft oder religion
wir stellen uns denen die versuchen in
deutschland zu spalten mit aller kraft
und entschlossenheit entgegen
ich danke ihnen